hi guys sci-fi recapped here today I am
going to explain the film called the kid
who would be king spoilers ahead watch
out and stay safe the movie begins with
a wizard named Merlin reciting King
Arthur's story following the death of
King Pendragon Britain fell into war
with people battling for power seeing no
end to the chaos Merlin created
Excalibur a sword to find the person
worthy of becoming King Arthur who is
later discovered to be the King's
long-lost son Drew the sword from the
stone and Rose to become a great king
this however did not please his evil
half-sister Morgana who desired
Authority for herself so her lust for
power eventually drove her to use black
magic however Arthur and his Knights
defeated Morgana and banished her to the
underworld before being dragged into the
underworld she swore to return for the
sword when the world would be at its
worst in the present day twelve-year-old
Alexander is getting late for school
because of which his mother is nagging
at him on the way to school he receives
a text from his friend betters who is
being bullied at school by Lance and
Kaye when Alex learns of this he rushes
to save his friend and instructs the two
bullies to leave Bettors alone Lance
then tries to scare Alex and warns him
to stop pretending to be a hero before
leaving the scene however as he walks
away Alex jumps on him and repeatedly
hits him in front of the other kids the
following day the two bullies Chase Alex
in order to finish the fight from the
previous day being scared Alex rushes
away trying to get away from them
however his Escape leads him to a
construction site where he is soon
cornered by the bullies as they approach
Alex he walks backward in fear only to
fall and become unconscious the sight of
an unconscious Alex frightens the two
bullies so they immediately flee from
the scene soon after they leave Alex
wakes up and discovers a sword embedded
in a stone while exploring around the
area he eventually pulls it out and
takes it back with him meanwhile Morgana
has awakened in the Underworld sensing
that the sword has been drawn out by the
new king she uses her dark magic to
order Vines to find out the person who
now wields the sword on his way home
Alex calls betters over to show him the
sword after ciphering what is engraved
on the sword they realize it is
Excalibur King Arthur's sword they
however do not take it seriously and
instead Alex takes the sword and
jokingly Knights batters elsewhere
Merlin who now resembles a young boy
senses that the sword has been
discovered and walks out into town in
search of the person who now possesses
the sword he eventually finds his way to
Alex's school where he pretends to be a
Schoolboy in order to get closer to Alex
in the meantime he hears from a teacher
that an eclipse is approaching in four
days which drives him to panic he later
storms into the cafeteria to tell Alex
that he knows he drew Excalibur out and
that Morgana will return When the
eclipse occurs however this only causes
other kids in the cafeteria to harass
him and throw things at him later that
night Morgana sends a demon to kill Alex
after seeing the demon Alex runs to find
his mom who is nowhere to be seen seeing
no other option he rushes to get
Excalibur and tries to fight the demon
only for the demon to fling the sword
away in seconds just when the demon is
about to attack attack our new king
Merlin uses his power to destroy it
following this Merlin immediately leaves
in his owl form since it is dangerous
for him to be in the Mortal realm after
Sunset before leaving he hands Alex a
fried chicken restaurant flyer and tells
him to meet him there the next day the
next day Alex and betters visit the
restaurant to find Merlin afterwards
Merlin explains to the boys how Morgana
intends to return and enslave everyone
additionally he tells them that
morgana's demon will appear to steal the
sword after Sunset and that during this
time all Mortal Souls other than Alex
and his Knights will disappear young
Alex becomes terrified upon hearing all
of this and tells the wizard that he is
only a 12 year old boy and cannot take
the duty of saving everyone when the
boys try to leave Merlin transforms into
his older self and shows them a vision
of what would happen to Britain if
Morgana were to succeed in obtaining the
sword as a result Alex finally
understands that he is the chosen one
and that the world needs saving after
this the boys return to the construction
site where Alex had found the sword
surprisingly Lance and K also show up
there and begin making fun of Alex while
demanding the sword as a response Alex
however goes and puts the sword back in
the stone then he tells the two bullies
that if they are unable to pull it out
they must allow him to Knight them the
two bullies agree to it since they
believe it to be a joke and that they
will ultimately be the one to win in the
BET to their surprise the pair fails to
draw the sword so Alex commands them to
kneel before eventually knighting them
in the meantime morgana's demon rises
from the ground and begins to attack
them Lance first takes Excalibur and
tries to defend himself but the demon
takes no time to overpower him seeing
this Alex rushes over to help him and
then they all run away in an attempt to
escape from the monster as they try to
escape they notice that there are no
people in the streets which perplexes
Lance and K soon after that they see
three demons chasing them so they steal
a car to get away from them even though
K hasn't actually learned to drive she
takes the car and manages to hit and
ultimately kill the demons off as soon
as the demons are killed everyone
reappears causing a huge traffic jam and
nearly causing an accident following
this the four proceed to Lance's house
where Alex explains the entire situation
to the two bullets he then tells them
that he seeks to locate his father in
tintagel in order to learn more about
the location of the entrance to the
underworld and how to kill Morgana after
trying his hardest Alex eventually
persuades the two of them to join him
after leaving a note for his mother Alex
and the other three kids take a bus
heading for tintagel on their way Merlin
appears out of the blue and takes them
to a forest to teach them how to fight
using his magic on some trees however
Morgana quickly subdues the trees and
the trees begin assaulting the children
while they are fighting the trees Lance
seizes the opportunity to obtain
Excalibur for himself but the Demonic
Roots soon begin to suck everyone
including him into the ground after
hearing the children's screams for help
Merlin appears on the scene and quickly
uses his magic to send the roots back to
the ground using all of his strength
however drains all of Merlin's Vitality
so flees in his owl form after reminding
Alex that he must accomplish his duty
when Alex notices Lance has no guilt for
what he has just done he becomes enraged
and accuses Lance of ruining everything
and being a jerk this leads to a fight
between the two of them in a lake which
ends with Lance breaking Excalibur as
Lance and K walk away after apologizing
for the Broken Sword Alex recalls what
was written about the Lady of the Lake
in the book with a bit of hope he
requests the Lady of the Lake to return
the sword to him if she really exists
surprisingly it works and a hand emerges
from the late carrying a repaired
Excalibur this makes them all pleased
and they promise to work together as one
and never lie as the sun sets morgana's
demons appear to attack Our Heroes the
demons start chasing them till they
reach the edge of the cliff with no
other option Alex jumps off the cliff
and his friends hesitantly follow as the
demons jump we see Alex and the kids
hiding just below the cliff revealing
that they had not jumped into the sea
however the demons fail to realize the
trick causing them to jump into the sea
after are spending the night in an open
Fort Alex goes off on his own to
tintagel to find his father there he
meets his aunt who tells him the truth
about his father he was not the good man
his mother described him to be he didn't
care about his wife or son because he
was an alcoholic she also reveals that
it was his mother who gave him the buck
hearing all of this upsets him and he
returns to betters feeling discouraged
batters then attempts to cheer him up by
using a trick he learned from Merlin and
convince him that he is not hopeless
simply because his father is not a great
man Lance K and Merlin also soon show up
to give Alex a confidence boost
following this they ride their horses
until they reach the entrance to the
underworld as they make their way down
there they are attacked by morgana's
Vines which eventually entangle Alex's
Knights while his friends are Tangled in
Vines Alex eventually comes face to face
with Morgana she then tries to persuade
him saying that the world is a horrible
place and that the myths he believes are
all lies he on the other hand isn't
bothered by any of this this leads her
to transform into a fearsome flying
creature and begin attacking him with
fire from her mouth soon after that he
deceives her by offering her Excalibur
when Morgana comes to get the sword he
instead stabs her as soon as this
happens the building begins to collapse
on itself prompting the children to
escape before becoming stuck believing
that he has accomplished his mission of
killing Morgana Alex throws the sword to
the Lady of the Lake and returns home
with his friends the battle preparations
quickly begin with Alex knighting all of
them in Merlin and betters duplicating
armor and weaponry for the kids to use
following this they begin to create
traps and other methods to battle the
demons Alex and his companions also
teach the other children how to fight
meanwhile Merlin advises Alex that he
must trap Morgana and kill her while he
uses his magic to open a portal to trap
her back in the Underworld ensuring she
will never return moments later the
eclipse begins followed by Morgan's
demons rising from the ground some of
the demons are killed by cars driven by
case and the other children however
there are too many demons to stop as the
demons enter the school they are
ambushed by the students who have been
waiting for them with their traps as the
students fight the demons the entire
school gets chaotic however Alex soon
realizes that the demons are too many to
be stopped so he tells all of the
children to go to the rooftop meanwhile
Morgana arrives in her demonic form and
begins attacking the children with fire
Alex and the other kids manage to
entangle her with ropes as Merlin makes
his way towards her in his owl form
Morgana blows fire at him injuring him
seeing this Alex rushes to check on
Merlin while the other kids hold the
ropes that are entangling Morgana he
then gives the magic potion of liquefied
nuggets Coke and ice cream to revive him
soon after that Merlin who has become
stronger as a result of the potion uses
his power to open the portal following
this Alex manages to jump on Morgana and
ultimately strikes her with Excalibur
ripping her head from her body she is
then pulled into the underworld in
seconds while the other demons vanish as
the sun and other people return
everything has finally returned to
normal as Merlin bids Alex and the other
three kids goodbye they Quest question
him if everything will be okay because
the world is the same in response he
reminds them that not every battle must
be with demons and that they do not
require Excalibur for every fight this
teaches the children that they are the
only ones who can bring about change in
this chaotic World the movie then ends
with the Lady of the Lake pulling
Excalibur into the water subscribe and
hit that like button to help our Channel
grow turn the notifications on so you
won't miss any of our new videos thanks
for watching